Two of my very best friends are about to start homeschooling this year,
and I am so, so excited.
So I'm going to pack them a little
welcome to homeschooling box with some of my favorite things.
First we're starting off with some of my favorite games.
Guess who and Banana Dreams Junior.
If you know you've seen any of my videos,
you know how much I use these every single day.
So those have got to go. Also,
guess you can play the game.
This is an animal edition.
But also, there are so many fun things that you can use this game for,
like putting in new facts and use it for math and reading,
so this is super versatile.
Next I'm adding erasable pens,
and then I'm adding in some of the printables
and things that I have made just for them to use.
Like that begins with anchor charts,
this two digit with carrying over math game,
my ABC tracing letters, and these little.
I think these are just the CVC word puzzles.
It is all done! I can't wait to give it to him!